when you talk about the machines I just
want to clarify you mean electronic
voting machines and those because people
write to me and they say I'm worried
Mike pillow is gonna come after my
espresso machine my lathe my all these
other type I'm sure they do David now
you're just being sarcastic and the
little left-wing humor
that could be your headline Mike Lindell
wants to get rid of the machine I will
tell you this yeah we're in an apex in
history okay where the technology we
have out there like in in
um
Australia where they use drones to come
down and tell you to go back in your
house the stuff is going on there where
we have been robots and everything and
everything run by computers if you look
at the everything that can be hacked you
got you know credit cards companies get
hacked businesses get hacked yes um uh
Gaslight or gas we had gas companies get
hacked all these things that hacked when
they get hacked you have it all involves
money or insurance so you have you know
the good Geeks and they patch it up who
did this attack who did this Cyber
attack who broke into my computer and
they fix it and they put up better
protection virus protection but when it
happens in an election you can lose your
country that's all I'm about I don't
know I just wanted to clarify that
that's all if you if you're gonna take
an election which China was involved in
this I'll say it straight out you just
seen where the guy the com code check or
whatever it was uh call check I believe
in Michigan just got indicted arrested
and uh for China to be involved in the
2020 election that's when out that
actually went out in the news just a
week ago okay I'm telling you that with
with computers and we just did the
preliminary injunction down in Arizona
that judge said why why um their hand
county is vulnerable too and here's what
my attorney said he said you know what
when you have a computer you can you can
change one number you can do anything
you hack again and you can do it can
affect Millions where if you had to do
the same thing with paper
um you'd have to have a whole cabal of
people you would have to have thousands
and thousands of people okay in on it
instead of having you know to be
protected our elections need to be
protected they do all of our elections
right down to the school boards you
can't have people breaking in and
hacking into computers that's not such a
thing and David doesn't it doesn't it
bother you that these guys have never
said hey we have nothing to hide show us
what's inside these computers instead
they attacked Tina Peters who that image
is up on my platform Frank speech the
image is there it shows 100 that
dominion and the Secretary of State
Jenna Griswold committed felonies and
deleted the 2020 election Mike it's
really hard to do these interviews
because we have so many different things
that you kind of Jump Around
the dumb question about getting rid of
machines if you want to be a humorous
interview
um you know get rid of my espresso
machine
I'm sure you have all kinds of people
that's a headline Mike wants to get rid
of the machine I guarantee you that's
not gonna that's not gonna be the house
computers used in our voter rolls there
falsely inflated I appreciate you
clarifying electronic polling books
anything with our elections